America is dropping like a stone in
rankings of freedom as power accumulates
in one person expect that to continue hi
I'm Tracy Oppenheimer Friesen TV and
today we're here with Frank Buckley he's
a professor at the law school at George
Mason University and the author of the
new book the once and future king the
rise of Crown government Frank thanks
for coming in
Tracy thanks for having me he spend a
lot of time in the book on the growing
power of the presidency and how this
evolved over the years so can you talk
about how you liken this to Crown
government and some examples from the
Obama administration compared to its
predecessors we have evolved into a new
kind of Constitution and it's a
constitution that resembles that of
George the 3rd in England before the
Revolution and the Revolution was all
about how we didn't like that but now
we've evolved towards a regime in which
power is increasingly held by one person
the president and that makes him
something like an elective monarch
that's what George Mason called him and
he said an elective monarchy is worse
than the real thing an elective monarch
has the legitimacy conferred by a
democratic election and a king
hereditary King doesn't have that can
you talk about how a gradual process or
if it's really showing up more in recent
years well it's been a gradual process
in which power has been concentrated in
the executive branch and it got a
quantum change in the last couple of
years with President Obama I don't want
to say he's the only person who's done
it but in the last couple of years
increasingly he makes laws by diktat he
doesn't enforce the laws he doesn't like
he has a huge spending power and the
greatest of all powers whether to go to
war or not rests largely simply with the
president and if that's not a monarchy
I'm not quite sure what is a monarchy
you say that the founders initial
intention was not to have a popularly
elected president so we have one version
of what the framers were all about which
is separation of powers I don't think
that's quite accurate I think they were
chiefly concerned to
ensure that power would be diffused and
not held by one person a parliamentary
regime was more or less what the framers
wanted they thought that in nearly all
cases the president would be chosen by
the House of Representatives voting by
state the last time that happened was
1824 it could happen again conceivably
it nearly happened in 2000 but they
thought that's the way it would work and
that's how Parliament's work the House
of Commons chooses the Prime Minister
they thought the House of
Representatives would choose the
president why did that not happen
because of things that the framers
didn't anticipate we have a modern media
we have national candidates we have the
rise of democracy none of these things
were things framers anticipated and just
going back to your other point on
separation of powers you know something
that's ingrained in students as they
grew up is how important checks and
balances are as far as the separation of
powers is concerned right now Obama or a
president has slipped off many of the
constraints and instead of a device to
constrain a president it's one which
immunizes him from criticism by Congress
you see the president is the only person
elected by the country at large whereas
the leader of the House of
Representatives is elected from
someplace in Ohio you never heard of
you've got one person in the White House
of whom the media is made a rock star
and you have 435 fractious people in
Congress led by as I say somebody who
comes from someplace you never heard of
and it's no contest
so when Obama acts in ways people say
are unconstitutional generally Congress
simply lies on its back and and kicks
its feet up and waits for a tummy rub
from the president the executive branch
you say actually employs two and a half
million people can you break down that
number for us and why that leads to more
regulation this is not counting people
in the military by the way so it's it's
all of the people in the executive
branch and that includes the departments
and the Czar's and the political
appointees none of us is really subject
to the control of Congress so the czars
for example are appointed by the
president without
approval of Congress and the cabinet
itself is is a bit player cabinet
meetings are meetings where the
president tells the cabinet here is the
plan get with it and it's really the
czars that run things and that's not
surprising it's the story of the entire
first world but the difference in other
countries is where you have a
parliamentary regime you have a Prime
Minister who's accountable to the House
of Commons and he has to stand up in
front of them and I want to say this is
something that people should be worried
about generally and perhaps libertarians
in particular because the rise of crown
government as I call it is I think the
underlying cause of many of the symptoms
that people might object to presidential
governments are bad for liberty as an
empirical matter parliamentary countries
are freer America is dropping like a
stone in rankings of freedom as power
accumulates in one person expect that to
continue well Frank thanks again for you
talk about your back thank you so much
phrasing TV I'm Tracy Oppenheimer